okay guys in this problem a 10 acre area
consisting of mostly Apartments is
constructed as part of a Redevelopment
project it has been determined that the
time of concentration for this area is
20 minutes during the 10-year frequency
storm what is the peak runoff in CFS
from this area during this storm
according to the rational method so the
first thing we're going to want to do is
go to our civil reference manual and
type in rational formula method that
might be a weird thing to search for but
if you search for rational it will still
come up um and if you can't find that
it's worth noting that the next thing
you'll search for if you need when you
have to find the runoff coefficient will
be on the very next page so these two
things will be side by side
anyway the reference manual will take us
to the equation for the rational method
and we can write that
here
rational
method and the equation is going to be q
= c i
a q is our flow in units of
CFS C is
unitless I is in inches per
hour and a is in
acres um um so from
there these are the terms we need to
find in order to solve for the peak
runoff so our first term is our area in
this case and that's given right in the
problem so a = 10
acres next we can find r i that's going
to come from the given intensity
duration frequency curves here the
problem states that we're looking for a
10year frequency storm during a time of
concentration of 20
minutes so what we can do is use this
intensity duration frequency curve plot
we can start down at the 20 minute Mark
here and we can go up to the 10year
frequency curve so if we go up and stop
here we can see that the
corresponding rainfall
intensity or I is about
4.5 in per
hour so finally
we can solve for or rather can search
for
c um in this
case the problem notes that
that the area is consisting of mostly
apartments and this is actually
important in this case because as we
search
our runoff coefficient table we will see
that there is a section for
residential and apartment dwelling areas
has its
[Music]
own uh runoff coefficient called out and
this could be anywhere
between 0.5
to
0.7 now in this case we're looking for
Peak runoff so it would make sense for
us to use the largest value so we're
going to use 0.7
here and at this point all we need to do
is plug in those numbers so Q
equals
0.5 times sorry we just said it would be
0.7
0.7 *
4.5 in per
hour
times 10
acres and this comes out
to
31.5
CS which on our problem we can see is
going to be closest to
32 so the only things you have to pay
attention for in this problem are the
size of the
area what information is given to help
you find the right runoff
coefficient um using the time of
concentration to find the correct
rainfall intensity off of the correct
curve and understanding where to find
your equations for rational method and
your information on your runoff
coefficients
and that is it for this problem